harley quinn is making her big screen
debut in warner brothers Suicide Squad
despite being created back in 1993 many
see her as simply too Joker's girlfriend
since making the jump from Batman the
Animated Series to Monthly Comics Harley
has come a long way Halle Quinn we're
here to discuss who the heck is Harley
Quinn for bad guys it's what we do
Harleen Quinzel had a pretty typical
childhood at a young age she became the
victim of bullying by some Mean Girls
she decided to take matters into her own
hands after being inspired by Wonder
Woman putting on a Halloween costume she
took care of the bullies she got in a
little trouble and supposedly something
like this wouldn't happen again as a
teenager she earned a gymnastic
scholarship at Gotham State University
she used this opportunity to pursue a
degree in psychology when she struggled
with her grades she found other ways to
get by she managed to get a job
interning as a psychiatrist at Arkham
Asylum she admitted she had an
attraction for extreme personalities
finding them exciting and challenging
with a hint of glamour upon first laying
eyes on a Joker it was apparent she was
smitten the attraction may have been
mutual
Joker managed to place a flower and note
in Harley's office inviting her to see
him
Joker seemed to be flirting and even
offered to tell her his secrets he told
her a story about how his father abused
him after Joker managed to escape and
was returned beaten to Arkham Harley
snapped she rushed out to the store and
returned to Arkham reborn as Harley
later it was shown how Joker further
helped in Harley's transformation Joker
brought her to the chemical plant where
he went through his change without
giving her a choice he pushed her in and
her skin and hair were altered
Harley managed to capture Batman and she
mentioned her desire to settle down with
Joker Batman started laughing he recited
a story of Joker's youth verbatim
claiming he'd use that bit on several
others wake up Harleen he had you pegged
for a hired help the minute you walked
into Arkham
simply put Harley wasn't an abusive
relationship with Joker when she tried
making some special time with him he
grabbed her by the nose and threw her
out when he found out she captured
Batman and feared the other villains
would chide him for being a guy whose
girlfriend killed Batman his first
reaction was a smacker he even knocked
her out the window a four-story building
Harley felt it was her fault and she was
to blame eventually Harley was able to
move away from the Joker he often was
locked up or simply did his own thing in
a recent encounter she made it clear
where she stands with him when using his
mind games on her things quickly friend
violent as a two fought each other
Harley let Joker know she was tired of
the physical and emotional fighting and
that she was done with him
Harley now spends time with poison ivy
and other friends but is also forced to
take part in missions with the Suicide
Squad for more on Harley Quinn and a
Suicide Squad be sure to check out
GameSpot and GameSpot universe
now they say about the crazy ones huh